[Music]
hi everyone my name is Anna Migas and
I work as a lead UI developer at field
intelligence where we take care of optimizing and
simplifying the supply chain for pharmaceutical
products and we're working mainly in developing
markets namely Nigeria and Kenya at the moment
I also hold the title of Google developer
experts in the web Technologies area
the title of my talk is the secret web performance
metric no one is talking about and to get you all
on the same page with me let's start with the
short definition of what web performance is
so web performance refers to the speed in which
web pages are downloaded and displayed on the
user's browser so you assumed correctly we're
going to talk about web performance today but
I have a disclaimer to make we're going to talk
about more user experience connected to the web
performance and also how my perspective changes
after working for the project directed at the
African market so it will be from a perspective
of a of an average African user and you might
think well why should I care um Africa is so far
um I'm not really working on a project targeted
towards Africa I'll probably never will um well
truth is you never know I live in Poland also
never told our work and project like that and
well I'm currently Nigeria every now and then
um also it's not really only about users who are
in Africa it's also about users who tend to have
a bit different circumstances that than most of
us while using the web so this is a problem for
anyone that is using an old device that is located
in some rural area tries to access the internet
from from some remote places or even for anyone
who is using on a daily basis some like Enterprise
dashboards like very heavy in the data how to
optimize not really working really well in general
so when I started working on this new project
I realized that um what I told about with
performance first well when you start looking for
articles or like information about webmetrics uh
related to the web performance there's one
thing that you realize that the targets at
a very privileged user the created with privileged
user in mind and the case is that well it's normal
because I assume most people who are working
on this metrics are either from Europe from
us from Southeast Asia and they are like used
to a great connection at most of the time for
them what performance issues start mostly when
they for example go to the Metro or maybe when
they visit someone in some remote place but in
general like for them web performance is like
on a daily basis they're using fast device they
have a stable connection and uh I would assume
that most of the time these are people who are
working on the metrics and this is not the case
for a lot of users of the internet unfortunately
and even when uh when you start looking for these
metrics uh the official docs will uh will mention
how um which speeds uh for example like this and
that metric should be optimized for let's say 200
milliseconds uh for average Hardware so we assume
like users with average Hardware all the stats
that will um they'll most used to convince people
to start optimizing the web performance a lot of
them will will talk about like how optimizing 100
milliseconds of time give has given some more like
retail to a certain company like how someone sold
more or something and this is well this is um so
this is like a web performance optimization for
people who are already used to Quick websites at
most most of the time and for them any sloppiness
um it's weird but some users um for them the
good web performance is not achievable at all not
um they are just used to bad web performance so
I want to quote here a really good article about
um uh caching of the JS it has a really great
quotes in there so it says at a high level
there are two primary performance bottlenecks
on the web first networking which is the round
trip time to acquire an asset or data payload
from a remote server and the second is end user
device compute the amount of computational
power overheads required to the and the uh
required on the end user's device so let's start
with the networking as you can see the networking
definition from this quote is very similar to
the um to this of latency so the definition of
latency is latency is generally considered to
be the amount of time of time it takes for from
when a request is made by the user to the time
it takes to the response to get back to the user
so it means like the moment you open a website on
your phone on your laptop the request is made it
needs to go wherever the data is sold wherever
the CDN the server is and then back to you
so um you can imagine that the longer this way the
longer the weight and the problem is that latency
in most parts of Africa is really really high and
this is due to the infrastructure with it which
is unfortunately underdeveloped and will stay like
that for quite a long time they don't really have
uh almost at all CDN hubs in there so apart from
South Africa and some Northern African countries
so what it means that is that most of the websites
are hosted outside of Africa for example for
Nigeria I think around 90 percent of websites are
hosted in U.S so imagine going to the news site
and like the request needs to make it all the
way to the US and back from sub-Saharan Africa
um and the high latency means long time to
First Bite so the ttfp so it means like this
first bits of informational gets to you uh in
a longer time and to quote Harry robots while
good time to first buyer doesn't necessarily
mean you will have a fast website a bad time
to First Bite almost certainly guarantees
a slogan so as you can see we are already
guaranteed a slow performance from one of the
angles now let's go to the second angle from the
previous quote which was end user device compute
so this is about devices used and in Africa well
um obviously you have all types of devices but it
is very heavy on the usage of mobile devices in
there most users will will be uh with their mobile
devices and it's not like the uh using the mobile
device to view Internet now and then they come
back to the desktop device for some uses the the
handheld device the mobile is like the only way
they can access Internet also it was for example
the first time the the access internet was uh was
on the phone so I have a good quote which um about
the Nigeria so the country is considered a mobile
First Market where infrastructure and online
usage development skipped wide-ranging desktop PCA
adoption and went straight to the mobile internet
usage by inexpensive smartphones instead so uh
this last part about inexpensive devices yeah
there's a lot of users who will be having devices
that have a really low compute Powers there's like
for example a popular device a brand called techno
specific for specifically developed for this
Market which has two qualities one of them is it
is cheap and second one is that it is keeping the
battery level for a really long time because a lot
of times you're not able to to charge your phone
uh when the power is out um and this translates to
uh longer past compile times to quote adios money
time spent in past compile can be often two to
five times as long on phones as on desktop so if
in Nigeria around 75 users are only on the mobile
for them it's already quite a worthy experience
and there's a slide which probably will not see
what's really written on it but basically it shows
like the the less powerful device the longer it
takes for it to to pause the website so what it
means now that we have this data that came to us
with already like delayed because of the latency
our browser also needs to take time to convert the
scripts and all the assets we sent to the user to
show the website to the user and um if the device
is less powerful well it will take more time
so as you can see from both angles there's a
performance bottleneck for most of the users
in Africa obviously there are users who have
like Fast device those users who's going to
have who are going to have a Wi-Fi but a lot of
people will not and we cannot forget about them
so I would like to propose the new web performance
metric secret web performance metric patience
obviously this is a completely made up metric
and a complete quick click buys for for my talk
here this is not a real metric but let's
define it so performance metric how long
are you willing to wait for the website to
load before you decide it is broken and um
for those of you for those of you who had internet
early for example in like early 2000s in the 90s
um you might remember this experience that you
were able to wait for things like downloading the
song you can wait a few minutes or even more or
well video buffering was not really that much of
a thing but in general you were way more patient
with things loading than you are now and it's the
same like for example with people living on the
outskills when um the buses uh there's like one
bus going to the city and they know it can be
laid by a few minutes but it's always there as
long as they know that it'll come they're fine and
if you're living in a fast-paced city if Metro is
laid by a few minutes you're like really scared
so as you can see it's like just difference in
perception so if everything is slow for you if
everything like if bad performance is in general
bad for everything what can you do let's talk
about some optimizations so the thing that um
I feel is the most important for the user that
has a slow web in general is the visibility of
the system status so we need to tell the user what
is going on as soon as possible if we're able to
so um the design should always keep users informed
about what is going on through appropriate
feedback within a reasonable amount of time this
is one of 10 ux heuristics by Norman using group
um so I would like to propose these things make
sure to give user information as fast as possible
you want to tell them what is going on for example
oh we're syncing documents it might take some time
or um like if if you're for example uh if your
app is a pwa and you need to download the new
content you might also want to tell them that okay
now the content is being downloaded you also want
to tell them how long it's going to take if you
have the possibility to assess that in any way
and once any error occurs you also want to to
let them know what is going on and what they
can do about it if they can refresh if they should
contact the supports if they're offline as soon as
possible I really like how Google Maps does it I
know it's not really popular in here but in Google
Maps you're able to download the offline uh the
offline maps and I like how they tell you like
um all the information that this area can
not be fully included how much data will
take when you're downloading it will tell
you the progress after you download it will
also tell you how to use this offline
maps like what what is the real usage
if something goes wrong they'll tell
you that something is wrong you can
try again you can cancel so I think
like uh they're doing it really well
um another thing to take into account is a digital
literacy we're all here with developers we're like
very skilled as using internet in general and well
think about for example someone's Grandma who's
using the mobile phone for the first time it's a
really hard experience from people like that and
um uh one thing to do is to use Simple language
for a lot of people like they don't even know what
the browser is for them like there's an icon in
their phone that takes them to the Internet so you
might want to make it a bit simpler for them uh I
would also propose discouraging damaging actions
because while the people um that I've seen at
least in Nigeria were really patient and they knew
that downloads and like in general showing them
the website can be really long when there's like
any buttons or anything that can still like go and
click around and like oh there's a button maybe
this will speed the process so you might help them
not to for example navigate out from the downloads
also a good idea is to explain consequences
of the actions for example that pull to
refresh is refreshing the page and the
thing might start downloading again
um I I've seen this happen even for quite skilled
users if we're using my app like there was like
something sinking and they were like pulling
to refresh all the time because they didn't
understand what it's saying uh you want to render
initial information as soon as possible so just
make sure that some initial content is visible
without blocking the rest of the view if that's
possible because if things tend to get longer to
load um well for example you might want to give
the user the navigation it's like you know that
your home page is going to take longer to load
um you probably want to give them navigation so
they can go to like other Pages without having
to download like all the assets that are needed
through the home page you somewhat uh consider
loading bits of information at different
times without blocking the whole View
if you know that's some parts of the UI might take
longer to download also you want to avoid request
chaining and the round trips for the data so as we
talked about latency so imagine it's not only for
like first requests it's like for all the assets
that need to uh need to be downloaded to show the
page that takes longer than in places where the
cdns uh only buy and you might want to try to
optimize it just not to make it worse so this is
mostly about considering using the browser hints
and there are three I'm going to talk about first
first of them is preconnect which can eliminate
some costly round trips if we know that we're
going to be using um uh for example a CDN but we
don't know exact paths to the to the assets that
are going to be used so this is uh this is not
going to block the initial render of the current
page but we're getting prepared for for some other
um for some other uh assets and uh this can be
used using the real pre-connect with cross origin
because usually what you're going to do is to
use it with uh with some of the domains and use
um the second browser hint is prefetch and this
will fetch the resources and store them in cash
and it's again for the next future navigation and
the browser will decide uh if if it can do it at
the time it's just a hint to the browser oh if you
have some free time you might consider downloading
this uh item and storing it in cash for the future
navigation both these resource hints uh also can
like um um slow down the process so make sure to
like test everything if uh if they're making some
seeds and the third one um sorry and there's a
snippet how to use the the prefetch and the third
one is preloads which is for loading the late
discovered resources and the main example that is
usually used is like for example if in your style
sheet there is a font and only then it's being
discovered you might want to in the browser hey I
know that this font will definitely be needed for
loading this page and I know I don't reference it
earlier so here we go please start downloading it
early and for the fonts unfortunately you need
to use a cross origin too and you can give the
hints this as to tell the browser there's going
to be a font unfortunately it can actually cause
the double downloads but if otherwise the font
would be discovered really late it can be worth it
another tip is to Lazy load resources that are
not critical so if you have for example some
items that are like way uh way down on the page
someone needs to scroll their way below default
you might not want to force the user to
download them because they might never
discover these resources and for that
now uh it's quite a good support for the
um native loading flag so you can sell it mostly
for images loading lazy if you know that some
images are going to be down on the website for
some browsers it works also on different types of
assets not only images but well images are like
the most popular famous case for that um learn
about network resources scenes so Network resource
hints is a basically connected to the settings in
some of the user's phones it doesn't work for like
all all types of operating systems but in some of
them in the settings user can select oh I prefer
to the saver mode like to save data and you can
know about this from the network information API
you can access this information about user Network
uh it's uh it's sitting in the Navigator and uh
this way one user says okay I would rather be
in the data saving mode you might be considerate
about this request and for example not ship some
images to them uh instead shoot some out images or
nothing at all uh you might consider preparing uh
um less Advanced version of your website just to
let the user accomplish the task they're coming
in there for uh and these Progressive enhancements
for the users who are not using the save data flag
also you want to limit third-party resources so
unfortunately the first part of resources can
delay the initial load of the page and they can
be one of the heaviest things inside of your page
so you want to load in a synchronously without
delaying uh the most important parts of your
website for that you can use async or defer on
your script text and they're quite similar async
doesn't care about anything else once uh once it
downloads it will get resolved after the initial
Dom while the um it will be considerate of
the order of the script tags on the page
uh another thing is to test for back and
forward cash and you might not be aware of
this but uh this is now very well supported uh
in the in the browsers so back for it cache it
takes a snapshot of the current version
of the page and when user navigates to
another location if they decide to navigate
back the snapshot can be like immediately
immediately prompted to the user it's like way
way faster than like downloading the resources
again so if user clicks on navigation
item by mistake you can minimize time to
um and navigate back for the website so browsers
do it by default but your website needs to be
optimized for back forward cache to work well
and to know if it is optimized well you can go
to the Chrome Dev tools into application Tab and
inside of this cache column on the left there's
back forward cache and there's this blue button
which you can click on any route on your website
which will test back forward cache if everything
is fine back full cache is is used it will give
you like this green green information if something
is wrong it will tell you what to optimize it will
give you a hints what's not working why back
and forward cache cannot be used for this uh
uh also you want to avoid creating too many layers
so when the browser is starting to view the the
website to the user it puts like elements of the
website on separate layers and the layers can be
created for uh many reasons like fixed elements
some animation 3D transforms and many more which
you might not be aware of so each layer created by
the browser will take some devices resources and
for this less powerful devices it can even crush
the browser so you want to probably minimize the
amount of the layers that that you have on your
page and to see if you actually not have too
many of them you can use the layers panel in the
Chrome devtools again and it might not be easily
accessible to you so to see it you need to click
on this three dots in the right corner there will
be like more tools and from there you can go to
to the layers panel and on the left in the column
you will tell you all the layers are created for
your website memory estimates how much memory each
of them takes and what was the reason why they
were created so if you see some that shouldn't be
there you can you can try optimizing them you also
want to minimize website repaints again for less
powerful devices the repaints can can be heavy and
they happen when the user is interacting with the
with the page and they can and interactive
elements like hovering or something like
that can force the browser to repainted
content so you also want to minimize that
and to see it again free those many more tools and
this rendering tab in which uh you want to toggle
the paint flashing and just start interacting
with the page to see what's going on if you
don't have too many of these green areas and you
might want to optimize them if uh if if it helps
so to sum up let user know what's going on give
them the status updates as soon as possible lots
of information early avoid request chaining and
use resources to dodge some of the time that user
needs to wait lazy loads content below default
make sure the user doesn't have to download any
resources they will never see leveraged Network
information API we consider it of user settings
in the phone limit third-part resources and if you
need them try to load and load them asynchronously
uh optimize for back forward cache avoid using
too many layers and repainting the content to
make sure that everything is working smoothly
there's a list of resources I'm going to post
my slides on Twitter so you can check the
links yourself and thank you [Applause]